[Music]
what's up everyone this is Tyson
recently I got a new machine the SMX
2100 and it's in the middle of getting
set up right now but I thought in the
meantime it would be cool to bring back
one of our older Parts the Titan 123 M
and go over a few programming techniques
on this part this is programming for the
9xs so it's some highle stuff but I'm
going to explain it very easily so
anybody can do it on Master cam so
before we get started I want to shout
out orbital computers they make some
really powerful machines for CNC
programming for CAD cam especially when
you get into multiaxis 5 axis 9 axis the
crazy programs that Barry does on the
hel even if you're just starting
programming they have everything from
lower end to higher end machines so if
you need a computer for caten cam
programming make sure you check these
guys out you can't just use a regular
gaming or just a regular computer
because the type of computer the
graphics cards that it uses it's
completely different for Cad and cam
work so orbital computers check them out
so let's jump into our program so I got
my 123 program up here it's an older
program from about 2 years ago since I
last did that video it's a really good
video though so if you haven't seen it
make sure you check it out so I wanted
to go over this program it's got a
couple of cool little things in there I
wanted to tell you about a tool path on
the front side and then on the second
side and just a couple of General tips
and tricks for the N AIS so the first
pass I'm going to cover is going to be
the 3D opy rough passs that I use to
rough out the material on the front side
of the parts so this tool path when you
program it it's technically not a
multiaxis pass but Master cam does
something cool depending on the setup of
your tool and your
machine so the way I have this tool set
up right now it'll actually use the
spindle along with moving the tool so
it'll actually take advantage of the 9
axis and you've seen me use this tool
path before I think a recent example
that I used this tool path on was that
octagon pass that I did where I just
ripped out material from the center of
the part that's a really cool video too
if you haven't seen it cuz I basically
take an endmill to the center of the
part and just rip material outwards but
that was using the spindle along with
the tool so tool was heling in the
middle and then the spindle started
spinning along with the tool moving
upwards this is going to do something
similar with the tool cutting on the
outside while the spindle moves along
with the tool so I'm going to go over
how to program that one real quick I'm
going to bring my tool bar right above
the previous one and then we're going to
select
opu and we're going to start off by
selecting our geometries so I'm going to
hold down the the control key and I'm
going to
click click and click and holding down
control will select any similar surfaces
along the part so click those three
faces and that selected the entire
outside
Contour I'm going hit okay there I do
have to set an avoidance geometry but
I'm going to leave that alone so I can
show you afterwards what I'm going to do
and we're just going to move on to the
tool path
control and we'll select a
containment and for this because I'm
cutting on the front of the part with
the tool being horizontal we're just
going to select the OD of my part there
and that's going to be the containment
area I can leave it to compensate on the
inside so I shouldn't have to mess with
anything here for our tool I'm going to
select our 3/4 bullnose and Mill I'm not
going to mess with any of the speeds and
feeds just cuz I'm just showing the tool
path so if you want to know the speeds
and feeds I ran for this tool check out
the video video for the 123 M and here's
setup tab so what I mentioned before
we're going to select cais face along
with using the upper left of the spindle
and what that's going to do is it's
going to use the cais the spindle along
with the tool for our stock operation
I'm going to select our stock model
which was all of our lathe
operations and then for our cut
parameters I'm just going to use a 20%
step over which I've already got in
there I'm not going to mess with any of
the step down settings because what I'm
going to do is we're going to cheat a
little bit we're going to go to the
Steep and shallow and I'm going to set a
maximum depth to the very bottom floor
past my radius there and we'll set that
there and I'm actually going to do the
same for the minimum depth so select
that these are both going to be set to
2.4 in deep and what that's going to do
is it's going to force the tool to only
cut to that depth so I just want one
depth with my 20% step over and then we
have our linking tab I can make the lead
in and Lead outs a little bit cleaner if
I wanted I'm just going to make a little
bit of a bigger radius for the uh lead
in we'll use the same lead and lead out
if I was actually programming this I'd
probably adjust this a little bit
further but we'll hit
okay and we have our tool path now the
one thing I mentioned you can see we
have a rapid line that goes to the
center of the part
here so that's what I mentioned about
the avoidance geometry depending on the
part I'm programming sometimes I like to
generate the tool path first so I can
see what it's trying to do and then set
the avoidance geometry afterwards to
tell it hey don't go into these areas
that you're trying to go into so we'll
go back to our tool path for our model
geometry and for our avoidance I'm just
going to select the whole front of the
part here
so outside and inside there hit in
selection and then with our regenerated
path here you can see it's avoiding the
inside now we have a nice clean tool
bath tool goes around there the part
will be spinning along with it it starts
feeding into those
[Music]
flutes
so we're going to move on to the second
side for the second side there was a lot
of facing with shell Mills I used a lot
of big tools so that I didn't have to
finish with smaller tools and just kind
of saved a little bit of time there and
what I utilized a lot during that was
the transform and rotate tool path which
I use all the time and what that will do
is it it'll let me program a 2d pass or
really any pass that I want on one side
and then if I do transform and rotate I
can tell it what angle I want to rotate
the part at and it'll actually flip that
tool path to the other side so when I
post that program it'll actually rotate
the spindle and then do the exact same
program on the other side it's really
convenient and it saves a lot of time
the only thing you have to watch out for
when you do that kind of rotating you
have to make make sure your lead outs
and clearances give you enough space so
you back the tool off fully before you
rotate one other thing that I had to do
a lot also with the second side was
because there were so many faces at
different types of angles I had to make
a lot of different tool
planes and one thing I utilized a lot
was the quick plane function in master
cam so if I right click on my part and
go to Quick C plane I can select a
surface on the part
so we'll say this face surface right
here and it'll actually generate a tool
plane for me on the part it'll be listed
in your planes as quick C plane and if
you want to edit it at all or move it
you can it's already set with Z pointing
outwards from the surface that I
selected so if I was to make a 2d pocket
or a face pass or anything on that
surface it's already set the one advice
that I would give you which I did not do
on this part and I kind of regret it
after seeing it is name your quick sea
planes after you make them because if
you look at my tool planes I have a lot
of quick C plane one and twos there so
make sure you label them so you know
what they are so actually the tool path
that I want to go over on the second
side is the champer pass on the outside
here it's got a curve to it and it
follows along there so I'm going to
switch it up on this video and I'm going
to do a morph tool path which is a multi
access PA to ball track the champer and
I've used it a few times along the parts
one example that I have highlighted
right here is when I did it to finish
the radiuses on the parts so I'm going
to show you how to program that we're
going to go to our Milling tool path and
under multiaxis I'm going to click
unified for our tool I'm just going to
duplicate the tool that I have in here
my halfin f Mill so copy tool assembly
paste tool assembly I'll make another
one yeah just pick a nice bigger holder
stick it out a little bit farther until
I actually put it in the machine I'm not
going to know how long I need the tool
but for a lot of these multia passes you
actually need your tool sticking out a
little bit so you don't hit the Chuck or
hit anything when you're rotating your
tool because the tool moves a lot when
it's doing these five AIS 9 AIS tool
pads we're going to go to our setup Tab
and for our axis combination we're going
to select up right I'm going to leave it
under top for the tool plane selection
for our stock model I'm going to select
stock model 4 for your stock model you
want to make sure that it knows whatever
material you've already removed on your
parts that's all set and then for cut
pattern we're going to add a curve and
for the style we'll select
morph now we'll select the first
chain that's going to be to the
outside of the
Cher so want that red arrow I'm just
going to keep clicking next until it
selects the outside we're going to
select our second curve which is the
bottom line of the champer both lines of
the champer are selected if I was to
move this you see we got a blue line and
we got a yellow line next I'm going to
select our Machining geometries we're
going to select our
surfaces I'm going click all the
surfaces of this champer I got two
really small surfaces here so zoom in
and click those
got our whole champer selected seven
surfaces for our area I want full start
and end at the exact surface edges we'll
make sure that extended trim is turned
on I want it to start a little bit
further off the champer and then for
cutting method I'm going to use a zigzag
motion so it stays on the part and just
keeps going back and forth it'll do one
pass step down and do the other pass
from the other side so it's going to be
just a constant motion it's not going to
lift up off the part and then for a step
over I'm going to use a 10,000 step over
you're going to want to change that to
however nice you need your finish of
your part to be but we'll do a 10,000
step over there I'm going to go to our
extended trim tab and I'm going to tell
it to start 50% of the tool diameter
it's a/2 in tool so it'll start a/4 inch
off of the chamfer for our tool Access
Control I'm going to go to our output
format and we'll select five axis so now
it's going to be utilizing the tilt of
the upper spindle I shouldn't have to
mess with anything here I just have tool
Access Control set to surface depending
on the angle depending on what it's
trying to do you might have to set some
limits but I'm pretty sure we don't have
to on this tool path and then run tools
sometimes you might have to adjust this
I'm just going to try it at Auto and see
what it does for Collision control we
have it set to the flute of the tool if
it comes into any Collision it's going
to trim and reink it trim the Collision
only and it's set for Machining
geometries I'll turn on the second one
and that's with the holder the shank and
the shoulder of the tool and this one
I'll set to avoidance
geometries and we're going to select the
outside of the part so if it thinks it's
going to hit the outside of the part
then it'll retrack the tool along the
tool axis and finally on the linking tab
this is where would adjust the leadin
and Lead outs of the parts if I wanted
to actually program this the uh default
links I'm going to tell it to follow the
surfaces here I don't think it'll need
it but we'll set that there just in case
that's usually what I like to set it at
when I'm first programming my five AIS
tool paths so we'll see what that does
and we should be all good here so I'm
going to hit the okay button and we have
a nice blue tool path so again I
probably have to adjust lead inss a
little bit but if I was to back plot
this you can see we have the tool
swinging along the uh champer we have
our extend a little bit
there we don't have any purple on the
tool path so I don't have to adjust any
of the gaps the small gaps or there's no
issues with the linking so it's a really
clean tool path and if I was to post
this real
quick and run the
simulator got our SMX 3100 I'm going to
miss it I don't have the part in there
because I only simulated this one tool
cuz I don't want to wait forever for it
to generates if I was to run this tool
in the
simulator and we slow this
down you can see the tool
tilting and if I turn on the tool path
so you can see our tool so we have our
tool moving and our spindle moving along
with the tool so swinging along there it
swings the
spindle and then does the other side of
the jumer utilizing the whole machine to
make those
chamers so cool I hope that was easy to
understand I just wanted to show a
couple of cool little tricks on the SMX
3100 I'm actually in the middle of
programming and designing a new part for
the SMX 2100 which we just got so I'm
really excited about that make sure you
like this video subscribe to our Channel
and hit the notification Bell because
you're not going to want to miss when I
run our first part on the SMX 2100 so
stay tuned to our Channel thank you very
much for watching this video and I'll
see you next
[Music]
time
awesome so I got the 123 part here I
just wanted to share a
[Music]
few and actually change it so if you
want to use something fancy or something
disgusting like uh what's the one that
everyone hates comic SS